hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast organ on a chip improving
biological insight using in vitro micro
technology it is presented by Sabet
Airport PhD a professor on the Faculty
of the science and engineering
department at the University of
Groningen
I'm Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located at the
far left of your screen and type your
question into the drop down box it
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
V report I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you very
much Judy for this opportunity to talk
to this audience to you all about this
new technology organ on a chip for
improving the way we work cells the way
that we study throw outside of the body
I always start my presentation by
reminding everyone that actually organ
on a chip technology which is based
on a chip technology is just them late
in a long line of technologies that
people have applied to studying cells
and tissues over the years and when I
say over the years I really am talking
many decades really human beings have
always been interested in understanding
how their bodies work and have always
also understood that doing experiments
to figure that out the that
experimentation can be kind of difficult
the reason is of course that we can't
just simply open ourselves up and take a
look inside and and isolate the various
processes that are going on inside our
bodies
that's ethically of course not possible
and so medical researchers have long
recognized that you need to take cells
and tissue outside of the body and to
study it outside of the body in order to
better understand processes that are
going on inside the body Claude Bernard
was a medical researcher very well known
in his day he too recognized the need
for in-vitro research to understand in
vivo processes in his medical in his
study on experimental medicine he also
noted that physiological occurrence must
physiological occurrence must as far as
possible be isolated outside the
organism by means of experimental
procedures the isolation can then allow
us to see and understand better the
deepest associations of the phenomena so
that their vital role may be followed
later in the organism the interesting
phrase in it 8:00 meant is experimental
procedures he was a little vague here he
didn't really specify what kind
experimental procedures he was talking
about and that's probably because they
were they're very dependent on the type
of experiments that experiments that he
wanted to do what he and researchers
ever since I've been confronted with of
course is how to take tissues and cells
out of the human body and to keep them
oblak not and to keep them outside the
human body the issue is not only just
keeping them alive but also keeping them
functional so that they behave and
function as they do in the body as well
as so researchers have been had long
been confronted by the challenge of
developing containers in which cells and
tissue can be kept not only alive but
also functional in a way that allows the
information gained from those in vitro
experiments to be extrapolated back to
the inveigle situation so in that
context then there have been many
different ways that people have done in
vitro assays based on cells in tissue
this what I want to show in this
particular slide of course is a very
familiar form for experimentation the
microtiter or Michael wealth plates
these plates are quite simple
conceptually they consist of rows wells
which can be quite variable in terms of
their volumes depending on how many
wells and want to fit into a sort of a
standard well plate format these and in
fact you have many variations they
microfiber micro well-placed volumes can
range from illa li ders down to
nanoliters depending on how many wells
you want to squeeze into that standard
format clearly these having so many
wells next to each other can be quite an
advantage if you want to do many exams
at the same time and in fact we it is
possible to add solutions to wells many
are several wells at the same time using
multi pipetting and types of approaches
or robotic pipetting approaches
however arguably if you grow a layer
tell us at the bottom of a well to do
some sort of test on those cells your
presenting the cells a cultural
environment which is really not
particularly reminiscent of the
environment that those cells would
encounter within and so often times one
one needs to be careful then in the
interpretation of results that are
obtained in with cells in this very
simple format
there are many essays that have been
very well optimized for this format
being kind of a denote and Donoho
experiment you want to work out a
particular cellular mechanism or or the
mechanism for a particular cellular
response this is probably this it may
not be the format that you want to use
so this is where micro fluidics reliable
on a chip technology then comes in this
is a technology which first really
appeared in the late 1980s you see here
images which appeared in 1997 on CNN and
so these are these images have really
become quite iconic I think for
lab-on-a-chip technology you see on the
left
somebody holding a lab chip you see that
those these devices are very thin and
planar and they what they contain then
are networks of interconnected micro
channels and at the and those channels
are formed in one layer of the device
and that uncovered by a lid of some sort
which has holes in it often or which has
holes in it which allow then solutions
to be introduced or removed from the
channels that's what you see on the
left-hand side of this particular slide
the channels themselves look very much
like the photograph on the right hand
side in this particular case we're
looking at quite a simple channel
network when we see two channels that
intersect each other to fit in or to
have those channels it's filled with
different kind solutions and in fact to
do to manipulate those solutions to form
a small volume which can be injected and
separated or analyzed or whatever in
some particular way these channels are
quite small as noted here they are hair
sized to give you a better feeling for
that what that means the average human
hair it is has a diameter of between 75
and 100 micrometers and so that's that's
kind of the size range that people work
in when working with lab-on-a-chip
devices the correspondent in this
particular case talked of in the
chemistry lab two devices which are no
larger a dime or a quarter that
miniaturization of course
is really very appealing simply just
from the point of view of being able to
make small things however what's really
important is the function the improved
function that we achieve with respect to
liquid and lighting when we used devices
with channels in this size range and the
other nice thing is that we use micro
technology to make these devices the
these are technologies which were
developed and are started to be
developed in the early 1960s to make
electronic circuits in now we can use
the same source of technology to make
interconnected networks of channels for
shuttling around and manipulating very
volumes of solution anything the Redeem
of nano li there's an even speaker
leaders and that's a leaders the fact
that we're using this type of so-called
photolithographic technology to make our
systems means that we can make highly
integrated systems so very intricate and
dense networks of micro channels that
only to connect the one if you know
there and you see that that's here ask
particular slide this is the example
from 2002 of a microfluidic device which
it was two and a half by two and a half
Senate and which contains two hundred
which contained reaction chambers to
carry out reactions and volumes which
are less than a nanometer in fact this 1
by 1 inch device contains 2056 micro
valves in order to control solutions
blowing - they're pretty action chains
you see an expanded view of one of these
reaction chambers on the left hand side
of this slide in the center it's the
green strip in the center you see then
various channels leading to that
essential reaction chamber the one you
closest to the reaction chamber is
filled with an orange liquid in this
case the next set of channels leading to
the reaction chambers filled with green
liquid and so on but you need then B
valves to control when and you deliver
what reagents or what liquid to the
reaction chamber and we have 2056 of
those integrated into this device
in fact 256 reaction chambers are
integrated into the system and each one
of these holds less than one nano liter
of solution so the technology allows us
to do pretty incredible things with
respect to making tiny features and
highly intricate intricate and quite
complex systems what's fascinating
though is what you can actually are how
liquids actually behave themselves in
these channels so let's zoom in a little
closer and take a look then again at a
very simple micro channel network two
channels that are crossing each other as
shown in these four images these port
images are taken from a video which
shows the definition and definition
injection and subsequent separation of
two analytes in a very small amount of
solution the images were taken over a
period of 160 milliseconds as you see
indicated in the lower right hand corner
of each of these images you see then
that the vertical champ or the channel
running vertically and through this
image is filled with a solution
containing two fluorescently labeled
amino acids meaning glycine and this
sample solution is manipulated and
pumped so that the intersection is
filled
with the sample the arrows and the
images were added to indicate in which
direction the various different
solutions are being pushed in order to
carry out the liquid manipulation the
horizontal channel is not actually
visible in this very first image at 0
milliseconds because it's filled with a
buffer solution but you see that the
buffer solution is also being pushed
towards the intersection to contain that
time of solution that once the sample
has been formed at the intersection that
very tiny sample is injected as shown in
image be and it is then subsequently
pushed along with separation gentle
we're using electric fields you're
actually manipulate solutions and this
allows also to separate the
fluorescently label arginine lysine as
they are as they have different charge
to mass ratios and that's migraine at
different speeds in the electric field
what's great here though is that you see
that these two analytes are actually set
completely separated or over a distance
of only three hundred micrometers in a
time of 160 milliseconds this is a
microchip electrophoresis experiment in
fact if we were to do the same
experiment and conventional capillary
electrophoresis instrument it would take
us to em certainly 10 minutes at least
if not more and it would require a
capillary having a lot of 3200 spent of
meters or so and by being able to
miniaturize the actual separation system
we are able to reduce the time that this
analysis requires down from minutes to
just milliseconds and so what this is
truly the power of microfluidic
technology it allows us to manipulate
solutions in on such a small volume
scale that we can actually
Karia various processes much much more
rapidly and in an automated fashion the
injected amount of solution here just to
let you all know is 20 Pico liters this
is a hundred thousand times smaller than
the smallest volumes that you can form
from a micropipette so that's generally
on the order of one microliter or so so
20 Pico liters is a hundred thousand
times smaller
the other interesting thing is that the
elect is that the electric field
strength there's a thousand volts per
centimeter now if we were doing this
using a conventional instrument we would
require a special high voltage power
supply to provide that electric field
strength here though we can actually
just use a 12 volt battery to achieve
the same electric field strength because
we've managed to shorten the distance
over which the separation can take place
so dramatically so micro fluidics
was shown in the early 1990s to be a
spectacular way of improving the
performance of various analytical
techniques but it's actually ultimately
all about fluid and flow control and so
I really started to adopt this
technology to be able to carry out other
types of work and in fact we very
quickly towards the late 1990s saw that
people working with cells also wanted to
adopt this technology for their own
purposes and that's really because in
fact micro channels have dimensions
which are kind of commensurate with the
size with the dimensions of cells cells
also have dimensions on the order of
micrometers they're generally smaller
than the hair size channels that I was
talking about before but by introducing
cells into these confined spaces we can
in fact grow them or cultivate them
in environments which are far more
controlled than they would be if we
cultured those cells in a well in a well
plate and so and the ability to be able
to control the conditions to micro
engineer the conditions around cells by
placing them in a confined micro channel
oh you means that we can also think
about micro engineering that those
environments such that they more closely
resemble the invivo micro environment
and so that is the power of micro
Vanek's then for cell culture we are
able to use some micro technology to
mimic in vivo structures in this so a
micro channel for instance could be used
to mimic a blood vessel or other small
vessel that one finds in organs the body
we can use flow to actually perfuse in
cells or tissue in micro channels so
that allows us to deliver nutrients to
those cells and to remove waste products
being produced by those sounds much as
the body does as well we can also use
micro fluidics to define spatio-temporal
gradients which allow us then to very
carefully control the concentrations of
different species chemical species that
cells are exposed to that and that
becomes interesting from the point of
view of studying cellular response as a
function of molecules and so on so we
like perfe linux often a new and vitro
technology P which allows us to mimic in
vivo conditions more
currently four cell experiment and so
having a route to war in people like
environment should also allow us
alternately to get information its which
are better able to which will better
allow us to predict cellular response in
vivo and so insolently didn't find these
there have been many different things
have cells being cultured in
microfluidic devices and this is a 3d
deliberate co-cultures system which was
published by the griffith lab at MIT in
this particular case we see on the left
the plate with 12 of each of those wells
there are two wells and the bottom of
the left-hand well in each case contains
a porous membrane contained with many
many pores
having a diameter of 150 micrometers or
so livers are seated in into this left a
reservoir and they then occupy these
pores to form 3d liver cell cultures
which in fact rhythms start to resemble
the liver to come back accurately the
nice thing about this particular device
is that the right hand reservoir is used
to as a reservoir for medium and in the
set of eight pumps in the base of this
plate which allows solution to be slowly
perfused through the porous scaffolds
containing all of those petrol livers
and that the is humped back and forth
between the
[Music]
left reservoir and the right reservoir
in order to continuously deliver
nutrients and remove waste products from
those little essentially little livers
this device then has been used for
toxicology screening and drug profiling
and so on and really starts allowing
some very interesting types of studies
to be carried out what's very nice about
this type of device too is that it
allows us to start thinking about
replacing animals with this type of
technology so that we can actually
reduce animal testing as well all right
so you can see where this is all headed
I've already used the term micro livers
in all of these little pores in fact
using my micro technologies in general
allow us really just thinking about
producing systems with biological models
to its function biological function more
on the organ level so this is this idea
of truly replicating organs in
microfluidic devices but what is an
organ on a chip I think it's almost
quite useful to be able to just which
microfluidic device from an actual organ
on a chip experiment and so a very
useful definition is one published by
Botti on Inger & Nature Biotechnology
2014 their definition of an organ on a
chip is given you
it's a mulk microfluidic cell culture
device created with microchip
manufacturing methods that contains
continuously perfused chambers inhabited
by living cells arranged to simulate
tissue and organ eleven level
physiology it's characterized by micro
cellular cellular our architectures
tissue tissue interfaces physical
chemical micro environments and
perfusion and the levels of tissue and
organ functionality that are achieved
are not possible with conventional 2d or
3d culture systems so this is a an area
which is really random
I will show you probably the similar
seminal example of an organ on a chip on
lung-on-a-chip in fact which really got
people thinking of developing these
sorts of systems it's a paper that was
published back in 2010 in - in November
of 2016 I checked to see how many hits I
got for organ and a chip and chip in the
web of science and it was close to 2,000
papers at that point I did the same
check this month and in fact the number
of papers now is close to 4,000 so you
can see that there's an enormous
increase in interest in these types of
systems for doing drug testing and so on
but we're seeing that these systems are
also being proposed for and for other
emerging application fields as well all
right the reported organ ship systems in
the literature are as diverse as the
biologicals that they have been designed
to study and so in fact most examples
that you'll find are based on cell
culture models people and models are
devices where samples have been
introduced some into the device and
cultured to form kind of tissue like
that construct
I refer to these sorts of examples as
bottom comprising bottom of biological
approaches there are some examples
though that are based on organic
typically issue Sam where in fact actual
samples from tissue have been taken and
put into the microfluidic device I refer
to these as a top-down biological
approach and in fact I'll talk a little
bit more about work that we've done in
this area in a few slides all right and
so there have been a number of very
important examples of cell culture
devices which have led to the
development in my view of this concept
of organ on a chip we see here two early
examples of multi organ chips based on
cell culture the one on the left in fact
was first published in 2004 it comes
from the Schuler lab at Cornell
University what you see here are for our
or is a device containing four
microfabricated chambers and they these
researchers introduced cells from
representing different organs into each
of these individual chambers so this
particular device contains had a chamber
for a lung after liver as you can see
here and also for fat cells as well as
an additional chamber for other tissues
these these researchers considered an
example where NAT saline was metabolized
by the liver and and then helped further
through the system
it turns out that naturally at least
like toxic for lung cells and indeed
they showed that cytotoxic effective
with their device as a proof-of-concept
the device tips on the right is kinda
malaria in fact here we have also four
different micro dams interconnected with
each other and and these channels were
filled with cells representing different
organs in this particular case you see a
close-up of one of these compartments
and you see that the inner part of the
compartment actually contains cells
that's where the cells cultured and it
is surrounded by a porous barrier
which has been formed by arraying micro
pillars around the device and solution
is then profused around the outside of
the this micro pillar array and and
nutrients then diffuse into the cell
culture area to keep the cells viable
and functional this is really quite nice
it represents a further development with
respect to the system on the right on
the left the system on the left simply
allowed perfusion of cells directly with
solutions flowing over the cell cultures
on the right the nutrients perfuse into
the cell culture from an adjacent
channel this really mimics a little more
accurately of how that transport happens
in the body as well okay but these
remain cell cultures organ function is
not reproduced in these systems this is
an example of a liver on a chip where
micro technology allows also for the
fabrication of a geometric structure
which resembles a liver sinusoid we see
the actual sinusoid on the left hand
side here of this figure and the micro
fabric aided device at the center the in
a sinusoid liver cells are are grow next
to blood vessels as as shown here and
the blood vessels are lined with
so-called endothelial cells which
regulate transport of compounds from the
blood into the livers into the liver
tissue that endothelial cell barriers is
mimicked in the micro fabricated device
by an array of channels having very tiny
dimensions and you see that here in the
centre cells then are introduced into
the centre of the chamber here and
cultivated in this way so here we see
the beginnings of an organ on a chip
because the device also incorporates a
geometric structure which resembles the
actual organ structure or at least a
unit of the liver in the body this
though is the device that really gave an
enormous impetus or kick-started the
whole organ on a chip and development
this is was published in 2010 by Daniel
ha and Don Inger and Geraldine Hamilton
at the Lise Institute at Harvard this
device mimics the interface between the
a tiny lung sack or alveolus and the
circulatory system as if you see then a
schematic diagram of one of these tiny
lug sacs at the top in the centre of
this figure
and the underneath you see how a micro
fabric ADA device recapitulates this
particular interface the device consists
of two halves or a top half and a bottom
half which when put together forms a
sealed channels you see the side in the
central chamber is divided into two
parts by a porous membrane which is also
microfabricated epithelial cells which
are cultured on the top of this membrane
and new filial cells are cultured on the
bottom side of this membrane and the
endothelial cells are exposed to air
so they represent the the lungs the side
of the barrier exposed to air the
endothelial cells are then exposed to
medium in this particular case all right
so we've got a biological culture
containing two different types of cells
which represent this very important
interface in the body however what's
very unique about this device is that it
also breeds those two the two side
chambers in fact allow that chip to
breathe the device is made actually in a
very flexible silicone rubber material
and so that allows then the channels to
be to be deformed what you see here at
the center of the the lower part of this
figure is what happens when vacuum is
applied to those two side channels you
see that the the side channels shrink
and that causes the central membrane
with cells to stretch you can imagine
then if you apply vacuum and then
release vacuum in an oscillating or an
alternating sort of way that you can
stretch and contract the membrane at the
center of this device in a regular
fashion as well so to mimic what happens
to this interface when we actually
breathe
so you see here pictures of the device
as well and so these characterized
they're long on a chip we see here what
happens when the central membrane with
cells was exposed to silica
nanoparticles with and without
stretching in fact let us take a look at
perhaps in panel a here at the left side
in fact the intercellular adhesion
molecule I cam is upregulated upon
exposure to silica nanoparticles so
certainly the epithelial cells do not
[Music]
like the presence of the sinus itself
and nanoparticles they do respond to the
fact that those particles are introduced
to that chamber interestingly the
neutrophils are white blood cells are
also adhered to the lower endothelial
layer when a silicon nano particles are
introduced to the lung in part the air
part of the system and the quantitative
gene expression then is given in the
figure to the right you see that for a
control device with no silicon
nanoparticles added that the I cam
Russian is quite low that the same is
true actually when those cells are being
when the device is actually breathing
with 10% strain however the introduction
of 50 micrograms of nanoparticles per
milliliter to the device results in an
upregulation of I cam even when the
device is not breathing but you see that
that upregulation so that response to
the nail particles increases
significantly when the device is
actually breathing and so that's
actually adult you see here a different
representation of the same data in panel
h to the right hand side here on this
slide we see that when there is when the
membrane in the name that in fact the
percent translocation of nanoparticles
through that cell barrier layer is quite
low it's less than 1% however when the
device is made to breathe we see a
significantly higher percentage of
translocation of nano silica
nanoparticles through the very very - is
a quite a disturbing result because it
hears that the application of location
of nanoparticles alveolar back barrier
into the bloodstream in fact if we this
type of experiment done in a
conventional trance well it's these are
the white triangles in this particular
figure
and we're also no strain is applied to
the sound layer these conventional
systems also do not actually predict
this hi a translocation of nanoparticles
and so it looks from this type of
experiment it appears that perhaps the
conventional format for doing these
types of experiments may have under
predicted the effect of nanoparticles
and so one begins to see that adding
this organ function to our micro devices
changes the way that the cells bond to
external stimuli
okay so ultimately what researchers now
would like to do of course is to combine
many different modules and compartments
containing different organs in order to
be able to study more systemic responses
to external stimuli all right I'll talk
briefly then about an organic tippet
model for oregon on a chip a top-down
biological model that we've been working
with in my mouth
we encoding it i've worked over the
years with a so called
top-down liver slice model for a b tox
screening and this is a model developed
by my colleague cami photons and it
involves taking a very small core of
liver tissue from a rat liver or most
liver generally also sometimes from
human liver tissue that is available on
the hospital at that core and you see
that happening in picture a
on picture see you see the small the
rich issue being mounted on a pedestal
that is then inserted into a slicing
machine such as shown in panel D in that
slicing machine a blade then passes very
slowly over the top of the core to
produce thin slices of what these liver
slices look like in panels ian's and F
as they are sliced those slices are
collected and ice-cold and preservation
so what we have here to are ultimately
micro livers as well really with the
attitude that the architecture of the
liver tissue is preserved in these
samples and these samples also contain
endogenous enzymes and so on that's
particularly important for metabolic
experiments such as those done for a V
tox screen and hence this is a model
which very effective for their
development however the problem with
this model is that these liver slices
work very well for 24 hours or tended to
work very well for 24 hours but work
kind of short lived beyond that
experiments longer than 24 hours were
not possible and so a number of years
ago my colleague and I decided to see
what we could do with micro fluidics
right I said sure I'll show you how the
photos lab worked with liver slices you
see here the wealth the 12 well plates
that liver slices were put into so one
slice for well the slices were submerged
in medium and then placed on a shaker in
an incubator at 37 degrees Celsius and
in an atmosphere of 95% oxygen and 5%
co2 and then samples are collected
periodically after and after a number of
hours from those wells they're then kept
and analyzed separately and so the
medium that the slices are exposed to
contain drugs of some sort and what the
samples then contain are themá-- the
metabolites that are formed when the
liver slices metabolized and those drugs
now it's you would think that this is a
quite a sort of a simple way a
simplistic way of doing this type of
experiment people in the micro fluidics
world would look at this type of thing
and say well we can do this type of
experiment much better under conditions
which are more and evil like however
these assays were are extremely well
optimized with respect to in vivo
experiments and so in fact this proved
it was quite a challenge it's because we
needed to produce a system which was at
least as good as this as this particular
normal state all right so our hypothesis
was that perfusion should prolong slice
metabolic activity here we see a chamber
- hum which can cross section it's
consistent path and the inlet is at the
bottom is on the bottom of the chamber
medium is induced there
it's passes through the porous
polycarbonate member okay is pushed
upwards through the chamber when the two
halves are brought together then the
medium can be collected at the outlet
prefer their analysis the idea then in
fact is to insert or to suspend a liver
slice in this chamber and to allow the
medium
very slowly hera pheri fuse actually
around the slice and back out again
and so a compound of sort in the medium
is metabolized by the liver slice its
limit and our are collected in the
solution and analyzed later this
particular device then as a volume of 25
microliters it's really quite different
from the device from the wells that well
plates assay the flow through the device
is ten mics per minute continues
delivery of nutrients and removal of
ways alright so the initial experiments
involved but allowing liver slices to
metabolize 7f oxy coumarin seventh oxy
coumarin as you see on the right hand
side of this slide is metabolized in the
first phase to seven hydroxy cumin that
is accomplished by sip 450 enzymes in
the liver it can be seven hydroxy
coumarine can be further metabolized by
other enzymes to kind of glue core AG or
several other metabolites so in an
initial set of experiments we place
liver slices in wells and in our bio
chip and looked at the collected samples
from both systems and we analyzed then
those samples for metabolite formation
you see that all three metabolites are
formed in fact at this at the same
concentrations in both our bio chip as
was in well like the concentrations of
metabolites were the same for one liver
slice in one chamber and for two liver
slices in two separate chain
which were linked to one another with
sample being collected at the outlet of
the second chamber so this our this was
a good result because it meant that our
device could do is at least as well as
the well plate
what you see here though is that these
slices were exposed to a very high
concentration of a 7f oxy coumarin quite
toxic concentration for the liver and
yeah
professor foetus always used such high
concentrations in the wells in order to
ensure that there was an excess of miss
compound present in the well so that's
the enzymes metabolic enzymes were
always working at their maximum turnover
rate throughout the course of an
experiment so the delivers slice wasn't
actually running out of the toxic
aluminum however clearly it would be
advantageous to work at much lower
concentrations and in fact our micro
fluidic system allows us to do that here
we see the metabolites cumulative
metabolite formation over time for a
liver slice when the concentration of
7/8 oxy coumarine has been reduced to 75
micro molar and in fact we see that the
metabolic formation rate is constant
over time and for all of these
metabolites which means that the
nutrients are being delivered at a
constant rate and that the enzymes are
also functioning in a constant rate so
cost and substrate delivery means
constant and then emit satellite
production it also means the collection
of metabolites and small volume flow in
our system and that's great because if
we can compress our metabolites
molecules into smaller volumes that
means we have higher concentrations
available and thus better detectability
right from the beginning of our examples
that's an a type of experiment which is
possible and well simply because we
would be depleting the substrate and
quite rapidly at these lower
concentrations all right so our original
hypothesis was that micro fluidics could
yield blogger viability metabolic
activity and liver slices in fact that
was not that hypothesis was not
satisfied we did not see an improvement
in the 24 hour limited served in well
plates however that's at what that told
us in fact taught us was that Michael
micro fluidics is not enough to mimic
the in vivo situation however you if you
combine flow with other factors you can
provide suitable environments for slices
which do allow improved viability for
instance embedding slices and matrigel
improves the Phase two metabolism to
three days in fact and in fact selecting
the right median composition also allows
cell called slaves cultures for up to
five things as we showed in 2010 ok
micro clinics and they enable statically
told in Detroit experimental conditions
which is can allows us to do interesting
errands such as real-time online
monitoring a drug lab and satellites are
in vitro setting it did Oregon internet
now this is a non liberated in fact
where medium is introduced to you the
slice in the central chamber here and in
that medium differing levels of an
inhibitor for a metabolic enzyme in the
liver slice is added and so one can vary
in a controlled way the concentration of
inhibitor being delivered to the slice
over time and thus look at the influence
of drug drug interactions on metabolism
here we see how this experiment was
conducted the concentration of
individual oxime B was
increased by 20 micromolar every two
hours and that resulted in the seven
hydroxy Coomer and being produced to be
slowly but surely decreased over time
you see that here in the graph on the
right-hand side of this slide what's
also interesting is this following
experiment in this particular case the
outlet of three different chambers our
devices was linked to three different
injection loops for an HDL
chromatographic separation it takes 10
minutes to fill an injection loop and so
if you can have a fast enough separation
and in fact also around on the order of
ten minutes or so one can sequentially
fill and inject the content of each
injection loop on a regular in a regular
manner to get regular information about
what's happening in all three of those
chambers so to monitor in almost
real-time the metabolites being produced
by slices and not those three separate
chambers and so that allows for the
analysis of metabolites produced by very
the liver on exposure to different sorts
of drugs this is we looked at the
analysis of the painkiller diclofenac
and its metabolites you see those format
or you see poor metabolites in this
particular slide and this is the
metabolite of particular interest here
because it's chemically unstable and
turns out to be quite reactive actually
as well this is a metabolite which is
also nephrotoxic so toxic for the
kidneys and so it's important to be able
to study how much of this metabolite is
produced by the liver under different
conditions however
because it's unstable you and in fact
see in the concentration of that
particular and like decrease over time
and that's then masks actually the how
much of this metabolite is actually
being produced by the liver and what's
actually happening to it afterwards if
we do this binocular micro system we see
that we get a far more accurate picture
of how much of this particular Cataline
is beat over time and you can hear that
a realistic perspective in fact how much
of this particular metabolite is being
for these alright this we can also carry
out in Torun experiments here what we've
done is we've put an intestinal slice in
the left tantum part and linked the
outlet of this chamber to a second
chamber containing a liver slice just to
look at organ interaction in the
regulation bile acid synthesis by the
liver with file s so in fact the liver
produces bile acid the enzyme that does
steps of an a.1 enzyme if the liver
senses bile acid in its environment it
will tell this enzyme to produce less
bile acid down regulate that inside now
in of course the liver in the body is
preceded by the intestine found and as
it turns the M the ileum part of the
intent and also is affected by the
presence of bile acid it causes in fact
the formation of fibroblast growth
factor T which then also has an effect
on bile acid synthesis in the liver it
in fact also down regular regulates
that synthesis okay so we have here
something being produced at the
intestine having a effect and in fact
this is an interaction that happens in
the body the fact we can reproduce that
in a microfluidic device as well on the
left hand side we've seen the gene
expression for fgf 15 we see that in
fact this gene is up regulated when
intestinal slices are exposed to medium
containing bile acid so the slices are
behaving as even we then take a look at
what happens to the liver slices upon
exposure to medium containing bile acid
if we look at the single perfused liver
slice exposed to CDCA we see at Wyatt
25% down regulation of bile acid
synthesis however look at what happens
when we put an industrial slice in
series with the liver slice we see a
further down regulation of bile acid
synthesis by 60% actually how in fact we
can reproduce regulatory processes in
the body in our microfluidic devices and
I think this has great potential in fact
or carrying out not only bot types of
leaks their handle on more fundamental
biological processes in the body alright
so with the organ on a chip that bridge
the in vitro in yeah we can think about
integrating analytical found interact
your system for the evidence that I
showed you up until now was done offline
generally although sometimes we leave
our big device
directly into a mic resistant for
controlling vacation conditions
oxygen stones but also for analyzing
sell them at all I cried and think about
placing sisters at the inlet outlet some
variants of our test mold
liberalism as well for instance now the
determination of oxygen is kind of can
be kind of tricky if you want to
miniaturize it because even small
sensors can take up a lot of space in
our mortgage example and in this
particular photograph see the disks and
the liver slices but you see what
happens when you stick off to go even
smaller optical fibers into these 25
micrometer chips if you're if you get a
bit unlucky in fact you end up pushing
the liver slices aside or otherwise
perhaps damaging them even by inserting
their sensors we've then come up with
alternative with nicely dying liver
slice for fusion systems in which we can
actually determine oxygen consumption of
the slice this case we see the choice
chain here in the center we play an
oxygen sensor before after that chamber
in order to do measure consumption of
oxygen by the liver slice the chamber
itself and you see here then pictures of
how we managed to accomplish that and
it's four twice um NEC and oxygen
concentration around 600 Micra molar
that oxygen concentration is the same as
for for the situation where we have
where the slice in the chambers there's
no slice Integra is a significantly
smaller amount of measured oxygen at the
outlet of the device meaning that
indeed consuming oxygen all right
to conclude then a vioxx model organ
ships must be environment for cells
their needs for transport to and through
an organ ship system but that allows for
integration the compartments into a
multi or existence and for online
analysis so we can use it to our
advantage
micro technology is great because it
allows us to make microfluidic devices
but I don't think features in these
devices which allow mechanical
stimulation of cells and integrated
sensing cell application areas include
drug development but also personalized
about medicine especially when patients
themselves IV news so up incoming
applications and are for disease
modeling and regenerative medicine is
that I end my presentation I just want
to acknowledge my group member and
involved with this work over the years
Paul from Mitch routes the smiling a
young man the lower-left did a lot of
the work initial work for developing our
chambers for liver [ __ ] die second from
the left in the photograph at the top in
the top row above future omen integrated
oxygen sensors into our systems and I
have had other people work sounds and so
on thank you for your attention I'd be
interested to hear what thoughts do you
have
Thank You dr. V report for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is given the
definition you gave for organ on a chip
could either of these two examples be
considered organ on a chip systems okay
so I guess you're probably referring to
these multi organ devices that I showed
early on in the presentation
what Firsters were being used to
represent the different organs and in
fact I've really started to answer the
question actually by giving the
description of those two separate
devices we've got that cell cultures
were being used means that that were not
quite at the level of organization in
these devices which is representative of
an organ a cell in these devices anyway
consisted of single layers of cells a
single layer of cells does not really
represent tissue and does not really
allow the recapitulation of function on
a physiological function on an organ
level so those initial devices from 2004
and slightly later are were very
important examples at the time they
really stimulated people start thinking
about
how about how to recreate organ
functioning devices but those devices
themselves did not allow that organ
function just yet
thank you the next one is what materials
could be used to make the chips that
house the cells or tissues which
comprise organs on a chip and what are
the typical dimensions for these systems
so many different sorts of materials are
available for making microfluidic
devices these traditional material so in
glasses is a nice material because it's
transparent and we can look into so we
can place a glass device under a
microscope and actually look into it and
thus monitor cell behavior and so on and
I think that's an important aspect to
mention here a lot of the functional
studies for organ on a chip devices are
done using microscopes and so it becomes
important to use a transparent material
of some kind glass is one such material
as I've already mentioned however people
are generally are turning to polymers of
some sort to make these organ on a chip
devices silicone rubber material has
been used and that's an interesting
materially appeal to the moon or
whatever but it's also possible to use
materials which have been used to make
well plates and so which we know are
biocompatible I'm thinking of materials
like polystyrene or polycarbonate or
whatever the chambers in these devices
tend to be a little bigger than the
micro channels I showed you at the very
beginning of the talk when I was
introducing micro fluidics techno and
technology for doing separate
you know acids and that sort of thing we
can make very small channel channels on
the order of the diameter of a hair or
even smaller however if you want to
recreate organ function you need larger
numbers of cells you need generally
thousands of spelled and so lightly
larger chambers then which have volumes
more on the order of a few microliters
and so but yeah again it depends very
much on the application and the time
cell experiment that you'd like to carry
out thank you we have time for one more
question could the interval between
measurements in this example be
shortened in some way to capture
possible processes occurring on a much
shorter time scale so indeed I think
here referring to the analytical results
that I showed for the metabolism by
liver slices and micro fluidic systems
of substrates like seven ethoxide who
were in those studies we were sampling
medium from the perfused liver slice
incubation chambers and you that
sampling was happening once every half
hour or hour and analysis information
about liver slice metabolism every half
hour or hour in fact we could get
information far more regularly if we
went to an approach where we sampled
much smaller volumes of solution and
perhaps did separations in micro
channels
as small as the ones that I showed at
the very beginning of this presentation
so if we could sample just two people
leaders have done from our incubation
device and directly inject than those
samples into separation like the clinic
separation devices we could be getting
information far more regularly on the
order of every and that could give us a
bit of a bit more insight as to whether
there were processes happening on a much
shorter time scale thank you I would
like to once again thank dr. Vera port
for her presentation I would also like
to thank laberd's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 31st
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye